* gilligan you filthy mut*
Just casually browsing YouTube...
Nothing surprises me anymore,
there is nothing new, nothing interesting.
Wait a minute? Videos for kids!
"5 Little PewDiePie Jumping on the Bed"
No.
NO!
God no, god no!
AAAAHHH!
PLEASE!
(I actually thought this was a real advert...)
Stop.
To re- to react..to review this channel,
I need help, I need a meme expert.
Who do I call?
Calling Ethan!
Computer: Calling ethanbradberry
Ethan from h3h3 productions
Computer: Calling Ethan h3h3
*Epic music*
Yeah dude! What up, man?
Yeah, someone summoned me! What's going on here?
I found this channel.
It is too weird.
It's the weirdest thing I have ever seen.
I've definitely seen some weird stuff.
I think that I am probably up for the job.
Uhhm
Why don't you give me a look, and then let me get my initial reaction here.
I don't think you are ready for this, but okay!
Are you, are you?
I mean, I- look dude, I have seen some of the weirdest stuff out there.
This cannot possibly shock me.
(Famous last words)
♩5 little monkeys♩ *Pewds laughs*
♩jumping on the bed♩ *Ethan: Woah wha-*
♩one fell off and bumped his head♩
What the f*ck is this, dude?
That shocked me, dude.
i can't watch anymore.
Pewds: I can't watch.  Ethan: All right well, that's it.
That's it for us, this is it.
Ethan: For this episode of meme dissection, here Pewds: Thank you, um
Thank you so much for coming, I appreciate your help on
the meme experts.
♩Five little monkeys jumping on a bed♩ Pewds: This is just the tip of the iceberg.
This got, the jumping PewDiePies
it has a very nice form on the jump, like.
I like how it says rap in the title. *Laughs*
Oh yeah dude, this is some gangster sh*t.
This is some f*cking Ricegum shit. *laughs*
Dude,
Made in production with Ricegum.
Ricegum's hottest new hit, "Five Little PewDiePie Jumping on a Bed".
♩Jumping on the bed♩ Why are they calling me a monkey?
♩One fell of and bumped his head♩
Rude.
Like, I have heard a lot of new hip hop, this year
in 2016 *Pewds chuckles*
Kendrick Lamar's come out with some
really great tunes. This is probably the best rap song, I have heard all year.
That's why i wanted to show it to you, because I know you would love, and
appreciate gangster rap.
That's not even a meme, that's just good music, if I'm
being honest. *Pewds chuckles*
They have my actual shirt.
Oh yeah, dude.
Tthey did research.
They figured this out, this wasn't something they just put together, you can tell.
There is way more.
Are you seeing this?
*Ethan coughs*
Oh my god! You're taking on Hitler!
As a...
Pewds Animation: Ah, Ah. Pewds: He punched me right in the throat.
Pewds Animation: Ah, ah (What the...)
What is with the sound effects?
Ethan: This guy is just in his base- his grandma's basement. Pewds: It sounds like me, it sounds like me.
*Action music* Hitler: Argh!
Why does Hitler sound like me, too?
Hitler: Argh!
I beat Hitler, though!
I beat Hitler, everyone! *Ethan claps*
You saw it, first
World War 2 is done, dude
Thank you!
Learning Colors with Far.. haha I didn't read the title. Ethan: "Learning
Colors with Farting PewDiePie" What?
You wish you could dance like that, you wish you had those moves.
Ethan: I don't- *Fart sound* Oh, god!
Green.. Toxic.. P- poop farts!
What would you say if you walked in on your kid watching that?
Uhh, I would- part of me would be disappointed,
but then I'd just realised
it'd be... Equally worse if you watch a PewDiePie video
Ouch!
Shots fired at yourself!
*Pewds laughs*
Ethan: That's the first time. Pewds: Come on,
it would be the same thing, if they- like, if you had a kid and they would watch..
your channel you'd be like, "what the f*ck are you doing?"
Ethan: SON NO!  Pewds: Ok, so I found this channel,
through these, "Farting PewDiePie"
PewDiePie nursury rhymes,
but little, did I know...
So, this channel was made in 2011
Oh wow, they're classic.
They're old school, but!
Their first video is uploaded 2015
Oooooh!
I smell a conspiracy.
Ethan: They've been sitting on that property. Pewds: No, they bought
the channel!
Woah, was it something before?
I think so
Why the f*ck would they name-
Have a channel called, "Toys in Japan",
and- and name it, "Seadoco"?
Interesting, can we fig- can we look that up somehow?
Pewds: I don't know but I wish we could! Ethan: Can we super slit that sh*t?
Ethan: Let me, Pewds: I wanna- There is something going on here! -_-
I r- I roam the memes, and I'm gonna do some reasearch for you right now, dude. I am
on this main frame, and um..
I didn't find anything.
*Pewds laughs* Ethan: I didn't find
any answers, for ya
they making bank and uploading these, and
If you look at their
channel, literally
they uploaded another PewDiePie one...
"Gorilla VS PewDiePie", FIVE
hours ago. Ethan: You see that, "Gorilla VS
PewDiePie Superhero Battle Fingers"
They literally upload 7 videos a day!
The fact that this guy can make 5 hour
long videos a day...
yeah, yeah.
Is- is creepy!
and it's weird
What
is going on? In
this guy's grandma's basement?
*Pewds chuckles*
There's a sweatshop of Pixar
rejects.
Pewds: sitting... Ethan: Yeah!
Keemstar's evil... Indian twin
brother... Is in the basement... Working
on these videos. Pewds: That son- that son of a b*tch
I knew it all along.
♩Sister finger, sister finger, where are
you?♩ ♩Here I am, here I am, how do you do?♩Ethan: The f*ck!
I can't tell if they're trying
to be weird, or if they just are weird. Or if they are
trying too hard to be weird.
You know what I mean? Ethan: That's a really interesting question,
and I have to say, that this is just
This guy thinks, in my opinion, that this very normal.
Honestly, there's a- there's definitely a- a
metaphor here, because Trump is riding with like a, huge d*ck
With a syringe tipped d*ck. So he's like,
"That's like a metaphor for power, and male, uh and- and male genital", If I'm being quite honest.
Oh my god, what is happening?
I'm beating the sh*t out of a cat!
Oh god, that cat is like, freaky. Looks like he just had a load
in his pants.
What the f*ck is this? What the f*ck is this?
What am I singing all of a sudden? I want to see Ke- Oh my god stop! ♩Father finger, father finger, where
are you?♩ Pewds: No!
♩Here I am, here I am, how do you do?♩ Pewds: No! I can't do it anymore
♩Mommy finger, mommy finger, where are you? Here I am, here I am, how do you do?♩
There finger, momma finger, where are you? Here I am,
Here I am, how do you do?
OOOOOAAAAAAAAHHH! *Intense music plays*
*slow mo*
Ethan! No!
Ethan!
Come back to me!
*coughing* Hila do something!
Felix you gotta warn me before you put on little black babies like that. Pewds: I'm so sorry.
I didn't know. Ethan: You ca- you can't just pop that on, you gotta give me a trigger warning or something, man
I need to hold on and brea-. Pewds: How was I
supposed to know?
What the f*ck was that? Pewds: You never know what you're gonna get in "Toys in Japan", that's the thrill. It's like a riot.
This is my new favorite channel. Uh, I started this off, thinking it would be
something horrific but, I'm into this content.
Ethan: Dude seeing Hulk, with like, get a grab of that huge, syringe. Pewds: I'm into it.
Nothing's hotter than seeing Hulk skull f*ck Mickey, with a syringe.
Can we show this?
Pewds: I don't know! Ethan: I don't even know how to describe what I'm looking at without,
like, f*cking up. What if this was actually what's happening on the moon?
Ethan: Like, how do we know this isn't what's happening on the moon right now? Pewds: Uhhm... There's no evidence.
Th- eh, the thing though,
is that, even if I studied to animate,
I could probably not pull this sh*t up!
Pewds: Yeah, this is, this is a lot of talent Ethan:This is...
This is something special.I don't know how I'm gonna sleep at night, dude. Like I
appreciate you coming out here, like, I see it's a big project,
you asked me for help, that's cool. Pewds: Mhm
I'm... I feel this has damaged me, permanently.
Can I ask, by the way, how did Hitler make his way into a children's show?
*Pewds chucles* Like of all the things they had to choose from in the world, they chose Hitler?
This says, "Videos for Kids", let's watch it. "Five Little Kim Kardashian" *Ethan laughs*
What's with the nursery rhymes?
That thumbnail, agai- OH MY GOD!
♩Five little monkeys, jumping on the bed♩
♩One fell-♩ Oh my god!
Felix I need a minute, just to watch this by myself
Now that is some
weird sh*t. Ethan: What the hell am I looking at?
*Felix laughs*
*Ethan screams* Pewds: Ooooah!
It looks like he doesn't have skin on! *Felix chuckles*
Where are you, little monkey? Aah! Pewds: Eww! Ugh!
How is this for kids? It's a dinosaur
with a pacifier versus a giant dog.
*Dog barks* It's basically a me- oh it farts. Ethan: What the hell?
*Dog barks* *Baa sound*
♩Here I am,♩ Stop, stop, stop! Pewds: I-
Okay, okay. I-
What the f*ck? Yea, so this is the ♩Five little
monkeys jumping on the bed♩ original monkeys jumping on the bed.
Pewds: This is the OG one! Ethan: This one is actually good. ♩One fell off and
bumped his head♩
They did it! Oh my god! Momma! ♩Momma called the doctor
and the doctor said♩ Oh my, momma momma. *Pewds laughs*
I don't see what's confusing about this.
This is straight up, content. ♩Father finger, father finger, where are you?♩ Oh my god, oka- okay Ethan:*screams*
*Pewds laughs*
♩Mommy finger, mommy finger, where are♩I can't imagine any kid watching this and not just like, crying their eyes out.
Alright, so that was react to "Toys in Japan", or nursery rhyme videos, with Ech- Ethan
from h3h3. Check out his channel if you want more- do you do react videos anymore? Ethan: Not really, but I mean
you know, we've got stuff, we talk about stuff, we look at stuff.
Well, check out Ethan and the link in the description.
And thanks so much for watching, leave a like if you enjoyed, and as always...
Stay awesome, bros! *BROFIST*
If you want to make it on YouTube these days, just make long *ss videos.
F*ck any type of pacing, quality, ain't none of that. F*ck that, get out!
Get the f*ck out, quality! I told you!
I told you, I don't want you! Get th- I n- I never have to say that. *Pewds laughs*
You wanna make it on Youtube these days, you gotta have watch time,
and if you don't know what watch time is,  it's basically, you just gotta make long *ss f*cking videos.